Awesome.
Hey everyone,
thank you all for coming through.
Really appreciate it.
Um,
my name's Jordan Tibideau.
I'm here hosting God's side.
There's Toklas brought to you by top Topia go slash talk topia.
I have a lot of great talks on there,
Tim Ferriss,
Ryan holiday and whatnot.
Um,
so if you don't wanna miss out a great event,
go ahead and subscribe.
So God's side is someone who doesn't really need an introduction,
but I'm going to do it anyways.
So He's a professor of marketing and at Concordia University in a research chair
in evolutionary behavioral sciences and Darwin,
Darwinian consumption.
Um,
he also has a amazing youtube channel,
which is called the quit the Godfather.
The sad,
sorry,
the sad people call his nickname is the gospel yet the sad truth.
So anyways,
uh,
thank you all for coming through and let's give a round of applause to Dr God's
side.
[inaudible]
thank you very much,
Jordan.
It's a true pleasure and honor for me to be here.
Uh,
I guess my life has gone full circle because my doctorate,
uh,
which I defended 23 years ago was actually in a,
an issue of search,
which should be relevant to the top search company in the world.
Of course,
you'd do more than that.
Uh,
my doctoral dissertation was on a very specific problem,
specifically something called stoppings behavior.
When is it that we've acquired enough information to stop acquiring additional
information and commit to a choice,
which is a fundamental search problem,
right?
When you're choosing a mate to marry.
Of course,
there are many more people to sample from in the world,
yet we don't regrettably,
uh,
when,
when at the applies to which political candidate we choose which car we buy,
which person to hire.
We don't look at all of the available and relevant information.
Instead,
we look at enough information until the point when we say,
I'm ready to choose Toyota.
I'm ready to marry this person.
I'm ready to hire this guy.
So this was the topic that,
the cognitive processes of how we stop information search.
That was my doctoral dissertation at Cornell.
Then I went off.
Uh,
well actually,
so let me tell you how it all started.
The evolutionary part of my research career.
When I went to Cornell,
it was really to study consumer choice as a mathematical modeler.
And then I hooked up with a,
the guy who became my doctoral supervisor,
who was a mathematical and cognitive psychologist,
and he suggested that I go into the behavioral sciences first semester at
Cornell.
I had taken a course with this.
Oh,
what did I do?
What did I do?
Okay.
I had taken a course with this gentlemen,
Professor Dennis Regan.
It was an advanced social course,
and about halfway through the course he assigned,
this is in fall 1990 my first semester at Cornell,
he assigned this book.
Has Anybody heard of this book?
Has Anybody read it?
Sorry.
Looks cheap.
Cheery,
cheery.
Yes,
exactly.
Uh,
homicide is a book written by two pioneers of evolutionary psychology,
uh,
Martin Bailey and Margo Wilson where they offer evolutionary explanations for
patterns of criminality to the extent that there are certain types of crimes
that happen in roughly the same way across time across cultures.
There might be some underlying universal processes that explain these crimes.
And when I saw the explanatory power of evolutionary psychology and explaining
criminality,
I had my Eureka moment.
I knew that I would use that framework to study consumer behavior.
Now either find consumer behavior very broadly.
It's not just consuming coca cola and Starbucks,
but we consume religion,
we consume friendships.
Uh,
you know,
pretty much anything you can think of,
I could fit it under a conservatory umbrella.
And so this is how I started looking at how I could apply biology and
evolutionary psychology in particular.
The study are consuming nature.
And so what I'll do for today's lecture is offer you,
hopefully by the end of today's lecture you'll get a good sense of how we could
use Darwinian thinking and studying consumption.
Now,
as you might imagine in the social sciences,
I really straddled both the natural sciences and the social sciences has given
the work that I do amongst my natural science colleagues.
Of course,
they all say yes,
of course biology matters.
Amongst my social science colleagues,
the story's a bit more complicated because most social scientists in a sense,
the fine their belongingness to the social sciences club by their abdication of
biology,
right?
According to them,
what makes us humans is that we transcend our biology and so as you might
imagine,
I've had quite a bit of a rough ride.
Now the reality is that science is an auto corrective process,
so without being too gleeful,
the better idea is eventually went out and I think most people now are starting
to come around.
It's becoming less tenable to say openly that you don't think biology,
math is when it comes to human affairs,
but there are still some,
you know all the remnants who refuse to admit that biology matters.
Some of the key
is that you're typically here some of the key objections.
There are many more of these.
I discussed this by the way,
the book that's a Jordan kindly got for you guys,
the consuming instinct.
I discussed many of these,
the tractors,
but let me just mention a few very briefly.
So here's one typical argument you hear.
Well biology is great.
Explain the behavior of the mosquito and the Zebra and the dog,
like surely you can't use biology to explain human behavior,
right?
This is called the human reticence effect,
The exact same evolutionary principle might apply to every possible species
except humans,
right?
Evolution stops right here somehow are our brains come through a magical process
that's outside of evolution,
which of course is ridiculous.
Here's the second one.
You often hear that evolutionary psychology is dangerous because if quilt
justifies and condones reprehensible behavior,
so for example,
if you explain wild child abuse might happen or why rape happens or why men and
women cheat on one another in an otherwise monogamous union,
then somebody will come along in a very irate manner and say you're using
science to condone and justify these behaviors.
Of course,
you're not doing that,
right?
The oncologist was studies pancreatic cancer is not for cancer,
He's not justifying cancer.
He's studying honestly cancer.
And so if you study child abuse and rape and marital and fidelity,
that doesn't mean that you're for it,
but it doesn't mean that you're trying to come up with an umbrella to justify.
It means that you're trying to honestly understand these very reprehensible
behaviors.
Here's another one that comes up often.
This is what I call the,
uh,
but men are not taller than women because Tom,
not Tom Jones,
uh,
what's his name?
What's the actor's name?
Tom Cruise.
Tom Jones.
I'm showing my age.
Thumb Johns was a,
was a,
a sex symbol in the 70s.
Uh,
so Tom cruise or shorter than Katie Holmes,
it was his fault.
His ex wife.
Therefore,
Aha.
It's not true that men are taller than women.
The,
the cognitive bias there is that people take a single data thatum to falsify a
statement that holds true at the population level.
So if you explain on average,
men prefer to meet with Noubar fertile women,
more so than postmenopausal women,
someone will put up their hand and say,
but that's not true because my uncle Joe is dating an older woman named Linda.
Oh Gee,
Darwin is dead.
We're back to the drawing boards,
right?
Of course that's not true,
but again,
that's the cognitive bias that people succumb to.
And this one is the one that irritates me the most because it is the one that
typically is levied by otherwise sophisticated academics.
They say that evolutionary psychology is just a bunch of fancy,
full post hoc stories that you come up with after the fact.
Nothing could be further from the truth as I will show you,
uh,
in a few slides coming up,
this is going to be a bit of the technical part of the presentation and then
later I'll give you some sort of sexy practical examples.
So the epidemiology of evolutionary psychology or [inaudible] for short,
I'll just call it GP.
So the,
the,
the method of EDP is really comprised of three components.
When you're doing evolutionary research,
you really are doing these three things.
You first have to differentiae and I'll explain each each of these.
In turn,
you have to differentiate between what are called proximate and ultimate
scientific explanations.
That's a fundamentally important distinction.
And I'll talk about this in a second.
You build what are called neurological networks of cumulative evidence.
Very,
very important.
Again,
I'll expand this and then you'll also build what are called consilience trees of
knowledge.
Consilience basically means unity of knowledge.
Physics is more conciliatory than sociology,
not because physicists are smarter than sociologists,
but because physics has organized its knowledge base in a way where there are
these organized coherent trees of knowledge.
Sociology hasn't,
we can't agree in sociology whether there are,
there is such a thing as innate sex differences or not.
Okay,
so I'll explain each of these in turn.
So let's begin with this first one.
So here I'm going to discuss this one.
The difference between proximate and ultimate explanations.
Much of science operates at the approximate level.
Most Nobel prizes that have ever been won have been one at the approximate
level.
What that's proximate means,
proximate means you're trying to understand the how and what other phenomenon.
How does diabetes work?
What are some factors that increase the severity of the symptoms of diabetes?
These questions,
the how and what,
which is where much of science operates.
Those are proximate questions,
ultimate questions.
And by the way,
here,
people think ultimate means superior.
It's the ultimate.
That's not what it means.
Ultimate means the ultimate Darwinian.
Why?
Why would the mechanism have evolved to be of that form?
So it's not that ultimate explanations are superior to approximate ones is that
you need both levels of explanations to fully understand a phenomenon.
So again,
you will only studied these types of explanations.
If you come with an evolutionary lens.
Now you might say,
okay,
I'm not really quite following what this says.
So let me give you a very concrete example.
Take for example,
pregnancy sickness.
This is a universal phenomenon that happens throughout time and across cultures.
Women at a very predictable point,
and they're just station will experience pregnancy.
So the reason why we call it pregnancy sickness rather than the morning sickness
is because it doesn't only manifest itself in the morning,
although typically it does.
So we call it more generally pregnancy sickness.
Well,
what would be a proximate story to,
to tackle when it comes to pregnancy sickness?
Well,
how do the hormonal fluctuations of a woman affect the severity of her symptoms?
That's approximate question.
The ultimate question is why have women evolved this physiological response?
Why is it that women at a very specific point and their gestation actually
experience these very,
very ugly and unpleasant symptoms?
And the answer from an adaptive evolutionary perspective is that this is the
mechanism to protect the fetus in utero from exposure to pathogens at a very
specific point in the gestation called organogenesis during the first trimester,
if the fetus is exposed typically through food pathogens,
things that the woman will and ingest consume that could wreck havoc with the
development of the organs.
Therefore,
evolution has yielded a very elegant adaptive solution.
Women tend to be repelled from foods or other other sources that have high
teratogen values.
Will there'll be attracted to other foods that serve antimicrobial properties?
Pickling right?
The typical stereotype of a woman of a pregnant woman wanting pickles,
well,
pickling has an antimicrobial property,
right?
Women who experience more pregnancy sickness are less likely to have
miscarriages.
The outcome of the child is greater if the woman experienced his pregnancy
sickness.
So when a woman goes to her ob Gyn and he or she will give her a pill to
attenuate those symptoms from an evolutionary perspective,
you're doing the exactly incorrect thing.
Now you might need it because you might have to give a talk that they at Google
and you can't run every three seconds to throw up.
So from that perspective,
from that proximate perspective,
it makes sense.
But from an evolutionary perspective,
it doesn't.
So here you see the difference between a proximate perspective and an ultimate
one.
Sorry,
the the,
the,
you might not be able to read this very clearly,
but let me this,
this,
this now goes to the second point here.
I'm going to talk about how you build these normal logical networks of chemo.
The evidence,
how do you build evolutionary explanations?
And it was exactly the opposite of this idea that we just sit there with smoking
a pipe,
coming up with fanciful stories.
It's the exact opposite of that.
So here we go.
So here I'm looking at the biological roots of toy preferences.
Are Toy preferences innate biological,
or is it as social scientists?
Tell us the means by which little boys and little girls learn about their
sexist,
arbitrary,
arbitrary stereotypes.
Right?
From the social scientist perspective,
biology has nothing to do with toy preferences.
The evidence points very much against that position.
So what I've done here is I've built a normal logical network.
What's the normal logical network?
It's evidence stemming from many,
many different lines of,
of,
of well evidence that makes it unassailable that there is an inherent biological
route to toy preferences.
Yeah.
So I took a lot of effort to actually build this neurological networks.
So let's,
let's go through it very quickly.
So you could take,
this is from developmental psychology.
You could take children who are too young to be socialized.
In other words,
by definition,
they haven't yet reached the cognitive stage where they could be taught by mommy
and daddy to play with trucks and dolls.
And guess what?
They already exhibit those sex specific preferences.
Now you might say,
how did,
how do you,
how do you elicit those preferences?
It's either usually when they reach to one of the toys or the other or through
gay studies.
So little boys do look at trucks much more than little girls and little girls
will look at dogs and so on.
So already just that one line of evidence is casting doubt on the idea that
there is no innate preference involved with toys.
But let's go on.
Look at this one.
Cross species studies done with vervet monkeys would rhesus monkeys and with
chimps shows the same sex specificity of toy preferences.
That's not looking like it's all due to arbitrary sexist stereotypes from the
patriarchy that's go on.
Clinical endocrinology,
girls who are afflicted with congenital adrenal hyperplasia,
this is an endocrinological disorder that masculinizing morphological features
that masculinized his behaviors.
So little girls who suffer from congenital adrenal hyperplasia,
what do you think happens to their top preferences?
They become a lot more similar to boys.
It's not looking like it's all due to random socialization.
Does it?
Let's keep going.
If you're not convinced.
Cross cultural study.
Sweden,
by the way,
are there any Swedes here?
No.
Okay,
so then I'll bash on Sweden without
uh,
Sweden.
There's,
there's something called the hops.
That score half said was a cross cultural psychologist who scored countries
along different cultural values,
suite of all countries in the world.
Sweden's scores the highest on femininity.
So if there is a natural experiment where you could see whether toy preferences
in a feminized society would somehow flip Sweden would be the case.
So this person,
inventor,
inventor read 40,000 toys in actual bedrooms of little boys and little girls in
Sweden.
And guess what?
They had the exact same toy preferences as everywhere else in the world already.
We've reached enough evidence but let's keep hammering it.
So becomes unassailable.
You could do cross cultural studies would non western samples because you might
say,
oh about Sweden is still a westernized country.
So you could go to two cultures in Sahara and the North African region that have
absolutely no venn diagram interactions on many of these cultural values.
And yet the sec specificity of toys is exactly the same.
Let's keep going.
You could look at classics,
meaning ancient Greece and you look at at,
you could look at funerals,
funerary art and tombstones.
What is the art that's depicted?
Little boys are depicted with the typical sex specific toys and little girls
with a typical sex specific toys.
It's not looking like it's due to the patriarchy,
is it
pediatric endocrinology?
You could take urine samples from little boys and little girls starting at age
seven days until six months,
and you show that the more testosterone you have,
that will affect your toy preferences.
I won't go through all of it.
I mean,
I guess I missed one or two,
but you get the general idea by building these normal logical networks of
cumulative evidence stemming from completely different fields,
you then build an evolutionary argument.
This doesn't look like it's just random.
Just so storytelling does it.
Let's keep going.
Here's another example.
This one is a bit more controversial because we're talking about mating
preferences.
Men haven't evolved preference for the hourglass figure in women.
My goodness,
that's very,
that's very sexist to say.
No,
it's not.
Women,
by the way,
have very clear morphological preferences and the types of men they prefer.
For a sexually reproducing species.
You would expect that the two sexes would have evolved preferences.
It's called sexual selection.
The fundamental one of the fundamental mechanisms of evolution.
So let's see whether we can build an adaptive evolutionary argument to explain
this reality.
All right,
well,
it turns out that the hourglass figure medically has been shown to be a reliable
queue of fertility and health.
So we're not just building these evolutionary arguments,
uh,
you know,
while taking acid,
right?
There's actually epidemiological studies that demonstrate that if you have an
hourglass figure,
you're more likely to be fertile,
you're more likely to be healthy.
And so it doesn't take much of an evolutionist understand why they'd be
selection pressures for men to prefer women who have the body shape of Beyonce
more so than a male Olympic swimmer.
Okay,
let's keep going.
This actually one of the sites that studies comes from me,
let me tell you the background to it.
A few years ago,
one of my undergraduate students had finished his course with me and then came
to me at the end of the course and said,
hey,
I'd like to hang out with you professor side,
and maybe serve as a research assistant on some project.
I said to at the time,
I didn't have any research funds.
I didn't have my chaired professorship yet.
I said,
well,
I don't have any immediate money to give you.
So he goes,
well,
it doesn't matter.
I'll do it pro bono work.
Just give me a project.
I just want to hang out and learn from you.
So I thought about what project to give him and I contacted and I said,
all right,
I think I've got a project for you.
How would you like to surf porn sites for a couple of weeks?
To which he answered,
I love you.
Professor said,
what did I ask him to do?
I wanted to see.
Speaking of search engines,
the Internet allows us to really get access to cross cultural data very quickly.
I said,
go to as many sites as you can find online where they advertise online escorts,
feet,
women advertising.
There's sexual services.
My name is Linda.
Here's my height,
here's my age.
And usually they always give you their measurements.
Now of course it doesn't matter whether their measurements are true or not,
right?
Because sometimes people say,
oh,
but what if she's lying?
Who Cares?
That's not the point.
The point is what is she advertising?
Because what she's advertising is what's catering to men's evolve preferences.
And so I simply asked him to code the waist and the hip,
and by the way,
it gets you want to know later if you want to take the measurements,
uh,
women,
the preferred a waist to hip on a woman is 0.7 on a man.
In other words,
what women like in a man,
it's a 0.9.
Okay,
so 0.7 is that marker while the average across 48 countries that couldn't be any
more different than one another was point 72 exactly within what you would
expect.
Okay,
let's keep going.
Here is the hourglass across 286 Egyptian,
African Greek or Roman and Indian sculptures spanning several thousand years and
also looking at Joe Mont figurines,
155 prehistoric figurines.
Guess what?
The hourglass figure comes out across all those cultures.
It doesn't seem like it's due to the pervasive patriarchy as shown in
Cosmopolitan magazine.
Let's keep going.
I won't go through all of these because you'll get the point.
This one is the real killer.
You ready for this congenitally blind men,
men who've never had the gift of sight exhibit the hour glass figure preference.
Now you might say,
well,
how do they elicit those preferences?
They do it haptically.
They give different mannequins,
the congenitally blind men,
you know,
check them out and then they choose the one that's the hourglass.
That doesn't suggest that it's due to media images.
Those guys have never seen media images.
So again,
I won't go through all of these,
but systematically by coming up with data sources from completely different
fields,
you end up building an unassailable,
by the way,
none other than the Great Charles Darwin himself had precisely than that.
Now he didn't call it normal logical networks of cumulative evidence.
This is a term that came in later.
For those of you are interested,
you can check out a paper by Schmidt and pilcher that have that have done this,
but when he,
when he did origin of speech,
when he wrote origin of species,
the,
the book that introduces the idea of natural selection,
that's exactly what he did.
He came up with years of observations coming from many,
many different fields.
Which one put together,
makes his natural selection idea seem on a salable.
So contrary to what most people who don't understand evolutionary psychology
argue,
which is all we just come up with fanciful stories.
It's the exact opposite.
The evidentiary threshold that we set before we decide that something is an
adaptation is actually much higher than the rest of the sciences.
All right,
let's keep going.
So this is exactly what this curve is showing.
Here's,
here's the threshold that you'd like to reach and support of your hypothesis.
Here's the threshold that you'd like to reach to refute your hypothesis.
And basically each of those squares that I showed you earlier is systematically
leading us up to that threshold.
Okay?
All right,
so now that that was sort of the more technical part of the chat,
now that's kind of give,
uh,
give you some breathing room.
Our consumers born or made you often will hear this,
is it nature or nurture?
That's actually a false dichotomy.
And the example I like to use as the cake metaphor,
if you look here,
each of these are ingredients that constitute elements of baking a cake.
Then I bake the cake.
If I now tell you here,
please point to the sugar,
please point to the eggs.
You can't.
It's an inextricable mix of all of it.
That's what humans are for most relevant phenomena.
We are an inextricable makes of our nature and our nurture.
That's called the interaction as viewpoint.
Our genes interact with the environment.
So it's not only the environment as many social scientists,
things and no serious evolutionist thinks that the environment doesn't matter.
But what we do say as you have to take biology into account.
Now of course in my work,
what I do is I introduced biology to the business school,
right?
If anybody here has an MBA,
you undoubtedly have tangible Mba without ever hearing the word biology
mentioned.
That's crazy because the,
our hormones affect the investment decisions that we make if we're situationally
hungry or not,
we decide to make the decision a or B,
right?
So all sorts of very basic physiological realities affect the decisions that we
make,
whether we're employers,
employees,
consumers,
managers.
And so what I try to do is systematically introduce evolutionary theory into the
business school.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll skip this part because it might take a bit to,
to,
to cover.
Evolutionary psychology is not only about looking at human universals things
that are the same across cultures evolutions I called.
You can also be used to explain why cultural differences exist.
So for example,
some cultures have very spicy foods,
other cultures have very non spicy foods.
If I were a cultural psychologist,
I would simply stop at that fact.
I would simply point the Malaysians have spicy food.
The Swedish folks don't have spicy foods.
Good night everyone.
And ends there.
An evolutionist says no.
Why do culinary traditions evolve to take different trajectories?
Is there a fundamental reason that could help us understand why some culinary
traditions are spicier than others?
In this case,
here's it.
Very spicy Mexican soup and here's the very non spicy classic Swedish meatball
plates.
And there turns out to be a very good answer.
If you map the spiciness of a cuisine against pathogenic density across
different environments,
it's the data couldn't be more perfect.
Why?
Because in hot climates where there is a greater proliferation of food
pathogens,
cultures evolve to come up with a solution to a biological problem.
Therefore spices pay,
curling,
smoking.
Salting are all cultural adaptations to a basic biological problem.
So culture doesn't exist outside the boundaries of biology.
Cultures exist because of biology.
Nothing is outside of biology.
Okay,
here's a cool example to explain something known as the Var variety effects or
the variety effect is the idea that when you go to a buffet,
most of us will tend to overeat.
Some of us more than others,
uh,
because it triggers our pension for variety seeking.
When it comes to foods.
Now for some animals,
they have a very high metabolic rate,
right?
So if you are a hummingbird,
you have to eat roughly three times your body weight in a typical day just to
survive till tomorrow.
If you did that as a 200 pound individual,
you'd have to eat 600 pounds.
Well,
of course we don't have that metabolic rate,
but yet we still have this penchant to eat many different foods.
Which results,
for example,
if you go to an all inclusive vacation,
has anybody been been to club med?
Anybody?
On average,
it's I think five pounds a week.
So if you go for two weeks,
you coming,
I don't care how much exercise you do while you're there,
you're putting on roughly about 10 pounds because at an all inclusive resort,
uh,
it's almost impossible for you to not succumb to the pool of sampling way more
foods than you otherwise would.
And so it was very too cool examples.
Here's a,
I mean it's,
these are such simple studies,
but yet they explained something so profound.
Take m and m's that are one color or a multicolored.
The colorant is tasteless,
odorless,
and otherwise it doesn't affect in any way objectively what happens.
But which of these two do you think people eat more of this one.
Okay.
Because it's the visual system is being tricked into sampling more because of
the variety of colors.
Exact same study,
but using shapes in this case here is one shaped,
uh,
pasta.
Multi shaped does otherwise the past does exactly the same.
I eat a lot more of this one.
Okay.
Now this is actually a study.
This is one of the studies that perhaps,
uh,
I mean I'm fortunate enough that my work,
not only I received this tension amongst scientists,
but because of the type of work I do,
often the media comes calling.
This is one of those studies where the media came calling a lot and you'll see
in a second why.
So I took here at principal from animal behavior,
literally called peacocking,
right?
Where in this case you've got the male peacock.
Here's the hen.
And he's basically,
he starts exhibiting this type of signaling,
uh,
to,
to show the iridescence coloring the size of the patterns,
the size of the tail.
All of this is what's known in biology as a,
as a handicap principle.
Why?
Because for this animal to have evolved such a burdensome Pale,
right?
This tail actually goes against its survival and actually reduces the likelihood
of him taking flight and avoiding predators.
It actually increases the likelihood of a Predator seeing him.
So how could it evolve through natural selection?
It's certainly couldn't evolve.
It evolves through sexual selection because it is actually an honest signal of
his phenotypic quality.
He is saying,
look,
this spite the costs I am carrying for having this stale,
here I am,
I'm the real deal.
Pick me.
So I take this idea and then I apply it to human consumer behavior.
And therefore for all of you rich Google types that are buying the Maserati,
you're just lowly peacocks.
I got your,
I got you pegged from day one,
right?
What are you doing?
You're basically saying,
look,
your little pretend that are males.
You can't compete with me because it requires for you to play at a higher level
to reach my signal.
By the way,
the upper uppers,
the highest echelon actually drive very non fancy cars.
Why anybody?
Any ideas?
Yes.
Okay,
good.
Good answer.
No,
it's yes.
Okay.
It's almost that.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
especially within their social class,
right?
So let me,
let me say it.
So if I am a billionaire driving a Ferrari amongst my billionaire circle is not
really a barrier to entry for their signaling as they could match that as well.
Therefore,
it is an irrelevant cue to use to demonstrate my honest status.
The way that I would do that,
as I will buy a painting that a three year old could have painted and pay $100
million for it.
Now that's an honest signal.
It has to be wasteful.
Just like the Peacock's tail has to be wasteful.
Throwing away a $100 million on something that a three year old,
the gender it could do now.
That's impressive.
I'm mixing it up for you.
You guys are too politically correct.
Let's bump it up again.
Okay.
All right.
So therefore what I did in this study,
not a three year old agenda,
a prospective three-year-old,
the generative,
because at three years old,
he is trajectory hasn't been set yet.
So what we did here is we took this idea and we actually,
and I say we,
this is what my former graduate student,
John Fungus,
we actually got a a Porsche and a beaten up car at this wasn't imagine you're
driving a Porsche.
We actually rented a portion.
I always tell people,
try to get a granting agency to give you money because you right,
oh,
we're going to rent a Porsche for the weekend for scientific purposes.
While we did and what we did for this study is after they drove these two cars,
we took salivary assays to measure what do you think testosterone and what do
you think happens?
You put a young male in this car and has endocrinological system explodes right
now.
In retrospect,
you all say,
yeah,
of course that makes sense,
but guess what?
Nobody in the business school is looking at things like that.
Somehow hormones magically ceased to be relevant when you enter the business
world.
It doesn't.
It's an indelible part of who we are.
Let's go on.
This is not my study.
This is from some British psychologist,
but along the same lines in terms of the status of a car,
you think the exact same car,
a guy you put him in a Ford Fiesta or in a Bentley,
you think the same girl,
you do the same and you do opposite sex rating.
So for,
for this guy you ask women to rate just how attractive he is.
It's not how attractive as a mate,
which is a multi attribute,
just how physically,
well,
obviously his physical looks don't magically change if he's in a Bentley or not.
Apparently they do.
If you're a woman,
this guy is gorgeous.
This guy's of the generative.
But for men is that didn't matter.
In other words,
men that not evaluate the physical attractiveness of a woman as a function of
which status symbol she was associated with.
Now I could guarantee you that I could run the study and 50 countries of your
choosing and we will exactly replicate this finding.
We will replicate exactly this finding because the underlying phenomenon behind
this finding is rooted in evolutionary psychology.
It's not as though in Bolivia and in Nigeria and in Japan,
this finding would be different.
All right.
Same.
Same,
same thing done with uh,
a guy being shown next to a shady apartment or a fancy apartment and a woman.
Same thing.
This guy is gorgeous.
This guy is not,
men.
Couldn't give a damn where the girl was shown.
So you could do this with a million different products and you'll get the exact
same phenomenon.
Yeah.
This is a study that we're currently,
this is a myself with one of my former doctoral students,
strip out gale.
We've collected more data sense.
So this could be probably updated to 2015 maybe a,
here's what we do here.
We created ostensibly an online dating profile.
Here's the guy,
here's stuff about me.
Here's my favorite possession.
The only thing we changed is his favorite possession.
He either has a red Kia,
no disrespect to any Kia Kia owners or he's got the sport.
And then we asked people to rate to rate this guy.
Now let me give you the background to how I got the idea to,
to run this study.
There was a famous study than a psychology,
uh,
where they brought a guy into a room and introduced him by ascribing different
academic statuses to him.
Uh,
here is,
uh,
Joe Smith.
He's a lecturer.
Here's Joe Smith.
He's a associate purveyors,
Joe Smith,
right?
And then when he left,
they would ask the people to tell their perception of his height.
Well,
it turns out that with academic status,
you grow taller.
That's why I told my wife,
don't worry,
you're not married to a short guy.
You married to an NBA star
because the reality is that your perceptual system gets tricked by this status
queue.
And so what happened here,
this guy was judged as taller.
There was what we called a status allegation effect.
He became taller,
but only in the eyes of whom?
Women.
What do you think men rated the guy shorter,
which again speaks to the psychology of intrasexual rivalry,
right?
Both men and women.
Derek Gates,
same sex partners in a way that is perfectly consistent with evolutionary
principles.
In this case,
I am threatened by a guy who may have higher status than me.
So I then agreed them,
how would I then,
oh,
well,
he's driving a Porsche.
You must be a little short rent.
Right?
And so again,
you see how all of this psychology is playing into these basic evolutionary
principles very,
very quickly.
Let me do a few more of these car studies.
This is a study that was done a long time ago.
It's,
it might seem dated,
but it's actually a very powerful,
especially in California where,
especially in a place like the bay area here where a lot of people drive fancy
cars.
So the,
here's what they did in this study at a red light.
This was a field experiment at a red light.
They actually put this as the experimenters either.
It wasn't these cars,
this was then 60 in 1968 so I just put,
I just chose a fancy car versus a non fancy car.
And they simply looked at how long it took a person who was,
wait,
this person doesn't know that they're going to be in an experiment.
How long did it,
how many seconds when the light turns from red to green?
Do you exhibit cues of impatience?
Maybe you'll flick the lights,
maybe you honk.
Of course people were a lot more impatient when the car that was blocking them
was lower stockists.
That again speaks to certain submissive dynamics that happen within social
species.
In this case,
it's happening in a very modern context and the way that we respond,
uh,
on the road,
in this case,
another study,
you know,
more than 30 almost 30 years later,
they kept the status of the car constant that's blocking and then they looked at
whether the car that's being blocked with exhibit greater in patients as a
function of which car was driving.
If I am in a fancy car,
it'll take me less time to be irritated.
And again,
you could see these types of dominance,
submission and interactions across many social species.
Let's move on.
Now.
So far,
a lot of the stuff that I've been talking about,
it seems as though I'm looking at based sexual signaling,
but of course that's not true.
Women,
I mean the human context and not just human contexts across across animals,
women of course,
or females.
And the greater context we'll engage in sexual signaling.
So in this case,
this is a female
chimp,
she will exhibit estrus that she isn't a sexually receptive state by sending
sorts all factory signals that are very attractive to the males.
Her Genitalia will become and gorge will become enlarged.
And this is basically saying that she is sexually receptive.
So I took this idea and I thought,
well how could we apply this principle which manifests itself across many,
many species to the human context and specifically to the consumer context.
And the idea was to look at how women dress as a function of where they are and
their ovulatory cycle.
And what do you think we found when women are in the maximum,
the furthest stage of their menstrual cycle,
when they're ovulating,
they dress more sexily,
they beautify more.
Now that doesn't mean by the way that they look at an oblation show and say,
oh Geez,
did okay,
there's our relation.
Let me dress with shorts or skirt.
It's an,
it's a subconscious mechanism.
I feel more sexy,
I feel less bloated,
I feel more desirable,
my self esteem is higher.
And so all of these mechanisms ensure that a woman is more likely to advertise
herself and the mating market when evolutionarily speaking,
it makes more sense to do so.
Now these studies are unassailable because they're looking at very basic
physiological,
hormonal,
biological facts.
That's why I very carefully selected to do these studies because it makes it a
lot more difficult,
difficult for my social science colleagues to say,
Oh yeah,
but this is just due to learning.
This is just due to culture because they're so basic in their physiological
genesis.
Let's keep going.
Switching gears.
I mean at the end of a successful meeting encounter you,
you might have a child.
And so this is kind of the segue to this.
Here's a study that was done in Mexico and the Yucatan region where when a baby
was born,
people would say,
oh my God,
he looks so much like the father.
Even though objectively that's absolutely untrue,
that's absolutely untrue.
And that the morphological feature of a newborn haven't yet sufficiently formed
for you to be able to objectively say he looks more like the dad or he looks
like more like the mom.
So something's going on.
Not only the people say,
my God,
he looks so much like his father,
but which side of the family is more likely to say it?
The mother's side,
because the mother's side from an evolutionary perspective wants to send a very
clear signal to the father that don't worry,
this is your child.
So before we had the Naa paternity tests and we,
before we had the Maury Povich show where every second episode is exactly that,
we had to come up with a cultural mechanism to assure paternity certainty.
And the way we do that is by fakely stating,
my God,
he looks exactly like you.
And by the way,
if you're wondering why these two gorgeous,
stunning kids are so gorgeous,
that's because those are my children.
This has Luna when she was very young.
And this is Leo [inaudible].
They're now a bit older.
They're in southern California waiting for me to go to the beach.
I came from the beach to come to Google and speak.
Uh,
now I want to tell you a little fun story.
I've,
I've mentioned this story before,
but I always love repeating it because it demonstrates the power of evolutionary
thinking and understanding our daily lives.
Okay.
This is the actual,
these are the actual images,
the first images of Luna in Utero.
So for those of you who are parents,
you know that when you,
when you,
when,
uh,
the mother goes to the first time to the Ob Gyn,
usually you get those images.
Most people are very happy and proud.
They celebrate this.
They'll put it up on the fridge.
We were no different.
We put up this image and one day my mother in law comes over to our house,
looks at,
so some people are laughing because they know where I'm going with this.
She looks at you,
Oh my God,
God,
the baby looks exactly like you.
So I made my daughter famous because this was the first case in science where
the maternal side of the family was trying to assure a father of paternity
certainty in utero.
So I said,
should I be worried that you're trying so hard to convince me?
That's that.
That's your daughter didn't go behind the bushes on me,
so I think she looked at me,
she goes,
oh,
enough with your bullshit science stuff.
Shoot,
look at that.
And so it looks like she looks exactly like you.
Oh,
actually we shouldn't know she because we didn't know what sex it was.
It,
it looks exactly like it.
Here's a study that was actually just accepted for publication.
This is Galtee Farah.
This is myself and two other young folks who help us out.
This was,
this is actually the photo of my parents when they got married in 1950.
There's still both alive.
Uh,
this was a study where we looked at,
this is going to speak about paternity certainty.
So you might say,
how do you apply this and Consumer Behavior Watch,
this is the data here is from Israeli weddings where this author along with
these guys.
Then they asked me to,
they asked me to come in on the paper too to help with the evolutionary story.
In this paper,
by the way,
is the longest,
most circuitry newest paper that I've ever had in my scientific career before it
had been accepted for publication.
We've worked on this paper I think for more than five years.
Asked her through the peer review process.
That's how long it took to get this paper through for reasons related to
people's antipathy towards biological based thinking.
So let me explain to you what we did in this paper.
We had data from 30 actual Israeli weddings,
excel sheets where every person who attended the wedding we had how much money
they gave.
So in other words and the Israeli context,
you know you don't give toasters and whatever other appliances you just give
money.
So uncle Mordecai the high $180 a antenna,
$200 and so we had all this data and so we test the two things.
One of them is pretty obvious for you to guess.
The other one is not so obvious.
The first thing we looked at is the size of the wedding gift as a function of
the genetic relatedness between the giver and the bride and groom,
and what'd you think happens?
The greater genetic relatedness,
the larger the gift.
In other words,
people modulate their investment and others as a function of the the strength,
the genetic lineage.
Now you might say,
well,
I could have probably predicted this without being a fancy evolutionary
scientists.
The second hypothesis you couldn't hear it goes.
If you take,
for example,
your four grandparents,
on average,
they share each of them a quarter of their genes with you.
In other words,
the genetic relatedness is 25% if you stop the story there,
they're all equally vested in you,
but there's a second element to the story.
It's not just genetic relatedness,
it's genetic assuredness.
How assured are you over genetic lineage?
Well,
your maternal grandmother is assured of her lineage.
There is no such thing as maternity uncertainty.
Your paternal grandfather has two generations of paternity uncertainty.
Therefore,
we expect the maternal grandmother to invest the most,
the paternal grandfather to invest the least and the two other grandparents in
the middle.
So we took this.
What's the fancy term is differential solicitude.
We took this idea and applied it in the falling away.
Does the matrilineal side of the bride and groom give larger gifts than that
patrilineal side?
And the answer is yes.
This is the one for matrilineal.
This is the one for patrilineal.
So holding genetic relatedness constant.
When you come from the mother's side,
you give greater gifts and when you do from the father's side,
no one would have generated this hypothesis.
If you weren't coming from an evolutionary Lens,
you couldn't have even positive that hypothesis.
I don't want to spend much time on this,
but remember earlier I talked about concilium tree of knowledge.
This is exactly an example of a concilium tree.
When it comes to evolutionary theory,
you start with some general evolutionary principles that are now unassailable.
They've been tested over 150 years.
These lead to what are called middle level theories.
Kin Selection is the mechanism that explains why people or animals invest in
their kin more so than in random strangers.
Based on kin selection.
I could generate hypotheses about genetic relatedness and genetic assuredness.
And then based on that,
I just told you the study that I mentioned.
Okay.
Therefore,
what evolutionary theory does is it provides you with these elegant organized
trees of knowledge,
very much like you would expect in physics and chemistry and biology.
And so one of the arguments that I make and some of my evolutionary minded
colleagues make is that the social sciences,
we'll eventually have to go through the same revolution that biology did too.
They know working biologists says that evolutionary theory is maybe right,
maybe wrong.
There is no chemist chemistry professor who is for the periodic table and some
who are anti periodic table.
The same thing has to happen in the social sciences.
For us to have the same impact and same influence,
we have to agree that there is a set of core knowledge that after a while
becomes unassailable,
and the way you do that is by building these coherent trees of knowledge.
All right,
we're almost done.
Let me just read you a few quotes that are very,
very powerful to really drive the point home of the importance of biology to
everything that we do.
This is an exchange that took place on Charlie rose.
If any of you watch it,
it's usually late at night on PBS.
He brings all sorts of guests and they get into a really fun conversation.
This is Eo Wilson,
who's a very famous Harvard entomologist,
still alive,
one of the biggest scientists of the 20th century.
This is James Watson,
the code discover of the Helix structure of DNA,
double helix,
structure of DNA,
Nobel Prize winner,
and they're talking to each other.
So let me just read it for your psychologist.
Most of the practicing psychologists and theoretical psychologist and the vast
majority of social sciences were really determined in a lot of the intellect.
That wasn't our policy is,
you know,
in our philosophies,
our philosophies have no collection at all to their true nature of humanity or
what human nature is at a biological level.
This is still a huge gap and I believe that we will start to fill that in a way,
uh,
that will be useful in years.
Immediately head.
I see the coming the past century was the coming together of chemistry and
biology.
The century will be the coming together of psychology and biology.
And this is exactly what I do in my work.
I marry psychology and biology.
Now interestingly,
this might interest some of the folks here who are more practitioner oriented
practitioners of business are typically a lot less,
uh,
they exhibit a lot less animus that these ideas then academics,
because academics are typically vested within their paradigms.
And therefore if you come along on your biology horse and if they feel
threatened,
then they will put up resistance while the practitioner,
it doesn't care.
The practitioner simply cares about what works.
So if you're an advertising executive and my theories can help you develop
better advertising appeals,
go for it.
And so here's an example from way back in 1964 this could have been written by
an evolutionary psychologist.
Let me just read it for you.
Because advertising effective advertising is an appeal to human fundamental
needs,
desires,
and motivations as an appeal to basic human nature.
People the world over have the same basic need for food,
clothing,
and shelter,
the same ambitions,
the same egotism and the same temptations.
The setting changes the climate,
the culture,
the idiom.
But the basic human nature is the same.
This is basically evolutionary psychology.
It's looking at these human universals.
And then this one is also say,
this is,
uh,
the founder of one of the biggest advertising firms of the 20th century.
He's basically saying,
if you want to understand how to communicate,
you have to understand human nature.
Again,
this is very much of a evolutionary argument,
almost done
before I put up before.
Let me just,
sometimes I get people who say,
well,
okay,
but give me some very clear,
practical applications of,
you know,
the fancy scientific work you do.
Well,
here's one which will be the next slide.
If good marketers,
whether they know it or not,
understand human nature well,
if you develop products that are contrary to some basic principles from human
nature,
the product will fail.
Right?
So for example,
Mcdonald works,
well,
not so much because it gets celebrity endorsers to support it,
but it's because it offers you a product that might evolve the gustatory
preferences expect give me fatty,
tasty foods.
Well,
it's not difficult to teach most children around the world to like that product
because again,
as I said,
our taste buds have evolved too to like that because of the environment of
caloric scarcity and caloric uncertainty that we've involved in.
So here's an example that speaks to this idea of romance.
Novels are almost exclusively read around the world,
only by women.
There is no culture.
And if you could find that culture,
send me an email,
I'll make you famous.
You won't find it because it doesn't exist.
There is no culture where men are the predominant consumers of romance novels.
Now you might say,
okay,
so what?
Well,
if you want to understand female sexuality study the archetype of the male hero
and romance novels,
it does the exact same guy.
It's a cut and paste job,
irrespective of which country.
This at very different countries.
It can be Pakistan.
It could be Lebanon,
it could be Bolivia,
it could be Japan,
the male heroes,
the exact same guy.
He's tall,
he's a prince and a neurosurgeon.
He,
he,
he wrangles alligators on his six pack.
He,
he's reckless in his risk taking,
but he could only be tamed by the love of this one.
Good woman.
Boom.
I just read for you every single romance novel.
Not surprisingly,
every single cover,
the guy looks exactly the same.
He never looks like this guy who is this?
Is this some VP at Google?
I shall never be invited again here.
Okay.
Right,
so this is not because there is a conspiracy to promulgate unrealistic images of
masculinity.
It's because marketers understand what in this case appeals to women's evolved
fantasies and they provide a product that is consistent with that.
There was a company,
I don't remember what it was called,
that tried to move away from that.
They wanted to create a loo and new line of Romance novels that broke the
shackles of this.
Guess what happened to that company?
It died.
It died because it had a erroneous view of human nature.
It thought that human nature is infinitely malleable when human nature is
constrained
by biology.
So I'm almost done.
I think maybe two more slides.
This quote right here,
I've always joked that if I ever wrote an autobiography of my scientific life,
it would consist of one page.
Basically this quote.
Why?
Because this quote perfectly captures what I have faced in my scientific career.
This is JBS Haldane who was a very famous evolutionary geneticist and also a guy
kind of like Mark Twain.
He had this beautiful,
uh,
ability with words,
great quips.
He said,
when scientists go through a new radical scientific idea,
they go through four stages of acceptance.
When they first hear about it,
this is worthless nonsense.
This is garbage.
And my case,
you're applying biology to consumer behavior.
What kind of heritage are you?
You're a moron.
Okay,
stage two,
as the evidence starts coming in,
well,
this is interesting,
but it's a perverse point of view,
right?
Stage three,
this is true,
but who cares?
Quite unimportant.
Stage four,
when the paradigmatic wall breaks,
oh,
I always said so.
I've always loved your work doctor.
Sad,
right?
I still have emails and I say this with all due modesty,
I still have emails from guys who had written to me when they were at stage one,
but they don't know that I've kept that email.
Now they're writing to me at stage four.
Will you do us the honor?
But I thought I was a bullshitter who applied biology,
right?
Well,
because that's how science works.
It's an auto corrective process.
Hopefully the good ideas eventually went out
and we're almost done.
Last slide.
Very famous [inaudible] famously stated,
nothing in biology makes sense except in the light of evolution.
And if you walk away with nothing other than this one quote,
I slightly tweak this and say nothing and consumer behavior or in business makes
sense except in the light of evolution.
Here are some of my books.
Thank you very much for your patients.
Thank you
very much for your time.
Uh,
we're going to go through some questions.
If anyone has any questions for the doctor,
please head over to the mic right there.
If not,
I'm going to jump on the dory and we're going to go from there.
That's either really good news or really bad news.
Oh,
I got one for you.
Can you talk about,
um,
what male lions and step parents have in common when it comes to children?
Oh,
very good.
Yes.
I guess you saw my latest Joe Rogan appearance.
Is that what you're saying?
Meal Pal yet found the bug?
Yeah.
So what Jordan is talking about,
it's a fun idea.
Uh,
when you have a pride of lions,
usually there is one,
two,
three dominant males that's really ruled the pride.
And there'll be these bands of young males who are now looking to have their own
pride,
who will consistently test these dominant males.
Usually they will lose until one day.
Nature catches up to the older guys,
and excuse me,
they're either killed or they're ostracized.
The new males come in,
take over the pride.
What's the first thing they do?
They kill all the cubs.
They kill all the cubs because for a species that is going through engage and
substantial parental investment,
none more so by the way,
the human males across animals from a male perspective,
it makes no sense for me to invest in the genetic package of other males.
Therefore I killed him and that will lead females into coming into estrus.
Now I've joked that that's how you get a female lion into the mood.
You kill her cubs and the way that we,
in the human case,
we play by Barry White music,
some idiot on on on my comments wrote,
that's not how it works.
That's he actually literally took my words as literally true that that's how
you,
of course,
that's not the mechanism,
right?
The mechanism is different,
but it is really what happens.
You'll kill her cubs.
She comes into estrus.
Now,
how do you link that to the human context?
Remember the first book that I mentioned at the start of the talk homicide,
the book that sort of led me on my epiphany to apply evolutionary psychologist
consumer behavior.
While in that book they talk about how the number one predictor of having child
abuse in the home by a factor of a hundred times greater than anything else is
if there's a step parent in the house,
and this has not become known colloquially in science as the Cinderella effect
because Cinderella,
the story of Cinderella is there is the evil stepmother who loves her children
but as differentially nasty through her stepdaughter.
And so again,
here,
this is an example where people get upset because then somebody will raise their
hand,
well,
this is bullshit.
I was raised by his stepfather and he's lovely,
but nobody cares about your personal example.
It's,
it's at the aggregate,
right?
Okay,
they're smoking causes cancer,
but your uncle Joe smoked and he lived to be a hundred it doesn't matter.
Right.
But again,
people have this visceral response against it,
but that's an example of how you apply at behavior and Lyon context to the human
context.
What Tim,
his seat over here,
I'll make sure I've a live question
with the example of the Porsche.
Yeah,
like it's an expensive item and it's,
it sounds really cool.
I think that's kind of like a,
I guess more of a complex,
like there's like a cultural or some sort of higher level,
um,
recognition there.
So like,
but it evokes like a primitive kind of response.
is there any research into that or anything you'd like you've heard about that?
Because I'm not sure I follow the question.
Can you rephrase it?
Like a Porsche,
like we,
we know a Porsche is inexpensive,
like kind of like sexy,
like object and having one increases status,
but like the recognition that a Porsche is expensive and it sounds really cool
and stuff like that that's like requires,
there's a higher level processing.
So like,
like how does our biological writes things?
So the underlying mechanism is,
of course not the Porsche related,
right?
In other words,
it's in the current cultural context that status has become associated with the
Porsche,
that,
that that's what we get in other cultures.
That might be the number,
the number of cattle head that I own.
And another culture it might be whether I'm a faint famous painter,
right.
Uh,
because Saul was a profoundly unattractive mail by any measure.
He was short,
he was bald,
he was overweight.
He was not particularly attractive in any way yet he had the extremely long
lineup of women who are more than happy to meet with him.
Very beautiful women because he was Picasso.
So the underlying phenomenon is not,
it's not as though we have jeans for Porsche's.
Right.
And the more that we have genes for pornography,
it's that these modern day products,
evolutionary principles that exist for us.
Does that make sense?
We'll do the next live question.
Yup.
So as an,
as an individual and consumer,
uh,
you know,
how does one use this knowledge to,
protect oneself from,
you know,
stepmothers and advertisers and you know,
mother-in-law's and things like that?
Well,
I mean it's a broad question.
I think to,
to use a cliche knowledge is power.
So to the extent that each of us has a key,
in this case,
evolutionary psychology to help us understand human behavior,
then it's a very powerful thing to have.
I will get students who took my course,
you know,
10 years earlier,
whole right to me and say,
hi,
professor.
Sad.
Uh,
I remember the lecture where you're talked about,
uh,
the evolutionary roots of romantic jealousy and I'm currently having such and
such fight with my wife because of such that,
and it perfectly matches what you were.
So in other words,
it's not as though there is a prescription for every syllable that I author to a
specific practical application.
But rather having that knowledge allows us to better understand everything.
It allows us to understand group dynamics of Google and why I'm going to fight
for the corner office because it serves as a status symbol.
So in other words,
I'm giving you a universal key for understanding human nature.
Thanks.
Cheers.
Well,
first of all,
thank you so much for giving this talk.
It was very interesting.
Thank you.
I'm going to ask you about one of the studies that you talked about the wedding
gifts.
Yes.
My question is how do you,
how do you come from the data that you collected?
How do you come to a certain conclusion?
For example,
in Lebanon,
I grew up there.
Um,
you know,
if,
if my granddaughter were to get married,
I would,
you know,
my granddaughter is more valuable to the family.
So typically families give more gifts to the female that's getting married then
and the guy that might be a reason.
There might be like other reasons.
How do you come to the conclusion that it's an evolutionary thing,
right?
Not,
not something else.
So several ways to answer that.
One is that as a,
as is the case in all science,
you have to rule out alternative explanations.
If you can't rule out an alternate explanation,
then your data is not as convincing as it otherwise could be.
But I also showed you how we build these neurological networks,
these neurological networks,
not,
not one of the boxes is enough to convince you.
But once I show you the eight boxes,
it becomes difficult for you to argue against my position.
So that's how you do it.
In evolutionary theory,
you,
you accumulate evidence stemming from many,
many different regions,
many different lines of evidence that it makes it impossible for you to generate
an alternative explanation to explain the phenomenon.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for coming today.
It's like,
yeah,
but amazing to hear your presentation live and not just on podcasts.
The second my question is through the lens of evolutionary biology.
How or what is your perspective on people that choose to use a plural pronoun
such as they are them?
Um,
since evolutionary speaking?
Sure.
They're born female or male,
right?
So I recently gave a,
uh,
for those of you who are not familiar with the question that was just Paul is
this is really sort of a big issue in Canada right now because uh,
there's a bill that was just tabled and pass called bill sees 16,
which incorporates gender identity and gender expression as part of the rubric
of hate crime.
So in other words,
if you do or say or not say or not do something that could be construed as
hateful towards say the transgender,
then you could be liable for,
to a hate crime.
And to the context,
uh,
for your specific question of gender pronouns.
A good friend of mine and a colleague by the name of Jordan Peterson got into a
lot of hot waters because he said he,
and he's a,
he's a very accomplished scientist who is a tenured professor at the University
of Toronto in psychology.
He said,
you cannot force me.
The government can't force me,
cannot compel me to use specific pronouns,
like [inaudible] say.
And so on.
Uh,
my Osi appeared in front of the Canadian Center.
Then I testified regarding that issue.
My position is,
okay,
there's a huge panel plea of personhoods transgendered people exist.
The non-gendered exists.
The nonbinary exist.
We should honor everyone.
We should treat everybody equal under the law.
That doesn't mean though that I have to celebrate your personhood by you
compelling me to come up with pronouns that are nonsensical.
So my personal position is that we're threading on dangerous waters with this
bill.
My point that during the Senate hearing,
by the way,
it was every single word that I uttered in today's lecture could be construed as
a transgression of bill.
See 16.
Because when I'm talking,
for example about an eight sex differences,
someone could raise their hand and say,
never in your course did you mention the transgendered or the non non gendered
or the Non Binary.
And that marginalizes me.
So literally evolutionary biology and evolutionary psychology could become
transgressive of this bill.
So while I respect everyone's personhood,
that doesn't mean that it should be anti-science.
Okay,
thank you.
Um,
you have a CV.
It's hard for me to sell on this.
I feel as though like it's,
I've got this,
you've got nothing.
No,
it's not.
It's forever on Google then you got to guess I'm sucking in accuracy.
So,
um,
your book is critical of religion and what are the positive psychological
aspects of religion?
Yes.
Great question.
Uh,
so in one of,
in chapter eight of my book,
for those of you who,
who took a copy that the book is that the chapter is titled Marketing Hope by
selling lies.
So that might tell you,
give you a general summary of what I think of religion.
Uh,
it's very hard to eradicate religion because ultimately we are the only,
uh,
being that we're aware of that is aware of its mortality.
And to the extent that we suffer from this existential angst,
our only solution to it is a subscribe to some religious narrative because all
religious narratives ultimately offer you a solution to this problem.
But here I'm torn because on the one hand,
I appreciate the fact that religion has some functional benefits,
but on the other hand,
if you truly wish to pursue truth,
uh,
then maybe believing in wrong ideas,
even though they feel good,
might not be the a good thing to do.
So.
So I guess my thinking is few people have the testicular fortitude to be
nonbelievers because it's a lot easier to be a believer.
What's the most exciting frontier of evolutionary psychology for you?
Oh,
great question.
I think it is to apply the principles of evolutionary psychology and practical
fields.
So for example,
in my case,
I apply it and consumer behavior in business.
Uh,
now there is the application of evolutionary theory in medicine.
Now you might think,
oh,
but it hasn't that been done already.
Know,
most physicians will never hear the word evolution ever uttered because they
work at the approximate level.
My good colleague who was,
by the way,
a guest on my show,
Randy Nesay,
one of the pioneers of evolution of medicine is now trying to make it part of
the curriculum of medical school that physicians,
future physicians be trained in evolutionary theory because there are insights
that come from evolutionary principles that you would typically not have access
to if you didn't have that Lens.
Uh,
there's a field now called evolutionary law where you apply principles from
evolutionary theory to understand whether legal codes are consistent with human
nature or not.
So I think the next frontier is to move beyond the study of mating behavior and
so on is to take the key of evolutionary psychology and use it to unlock
different practical fields.
Um,
going back to your comment in the car,
I had to reflect my own personal antidote.
So,
um,
I,
my first car when I got when I was 18 years old was a 1987,
uh,
for,
no,
it was a Volkswagen Fox.
It had about 200,000 miles on it.
Went around the sun multiple times I guess or something.
Um,
the engine was so loud that I could literally have like George Clooney and
Angelina Jolie in my car with a pile of cash and I couldn't get anyone to come
inside because the car looks so terrible.
Um,
but when I would drive to de Anza for Community College,
I got stopped multiple times for the car I was driving cause it looked like a
good stop.
But then once I upgrade my car to like a Ford Focus and put my Santa Clara
University like alumni plaque on that,
I haven't been stopped for like 10 years almost.
So it's really interesting because your book,
you talked about if you're driving a high end car,
people are more or less likely to honk when you were a late at a red light
compared to if you drive a cheap car,
people will honk right away because it's like,
who is this person?
Um,
but I wanted to ask you,
you had a point about how birth order affects our psychology,
right?
And families.
Can you talk a little about that?
Sure.
So there's this gentleman by the name of Frank Soloway who is a historian of
science and a Darwinist who came up with an incredible idea to explain birth
order affects.
Typically when you talk about birth order,
the,
sorry,
should I be looking at you or is it okay to look at everyone?
Yeah,
I'm just two hands on my,
uh,
typically when you study birth order affects,
it has studied from the perspective of how parents treat children of different
orders differently.
So they might treat the first born differently than the last born.
And that's at the genesis of birth order phenomenon.
Frank Salloway flip that whole script upside down.
He argued that?
No,
actually what drives birth order effects are the children themselves.
And let me just explain it very quickly.
It's actually an interesting marketing problem.
This is the fancy term is called Darwinian niche partitioning hypothesis.
So it basically works as follows.
When a child is born,
one of the ways that it has to secure maximal parental investment is to convince
the parents that it is uniquely different from all the other children.
Okay.
So there are many different niches I could occupy as a child.
I could be the good boy,
I could be the rebellious boy,
right?
So when I,
if I'm the first born,
all of the niches are unoccupied.
Correct.
Therefore,
I could pick any of them.
If I'm the second born,
I have n minus one niches.
As I go down the sip ship,
there are fewer and fewer niches for from which I can,
I could fill.
And he argued that that adaptive problem causes later borns to score higher on
openness to experiences,
to be greater thinkers outside the box because of this original problem that
they have to solve,
which is how could I be maximally different from all my other siblings?
And whenever I lecture about this,
I always end with the following and we guess what professor sides,
birth orders,
boom.
I was destined for greatness cause I'm last porn.
Uh,
I'm the,
I'm the last of four.
So that's
the explanation for the birth order effect.
They're still caught my eye cause my brother is like six,
three amazing athletes and whatnot.
It was getting recruited for college when he was playing for Bellarmine for
football.
And I was always known as Gabriel's little brother and I was like,
crap,
well I'm five,
seven nothing and I weigh nothing.
So I guess I'll be the one who either makes people laugh or is either like
studying really hard or whatnot.
The Guy Google here.
Right.
So it's funny how that plays out.
Um,
can you talk about the mobility,
mobility and friendship issue in the US?
How we're constantly relocating,
whatnot.
All right,
how can we overcome that?
So and so that part I was talking about cross cultural differences and
friendship friendships.
And one of the arguments that I've often heard,
so for example,
when I was in graduate school,
most of the graduate students who are not American would always say the same
thing.
That you could make friends very easily with an American.
But the friendships seem to be shallower.
They're,
they're sort of more ephemeral.
And so I was just thinking of,
well,
why is that?
I mean,
it can't be because Americans are,
you know,
more shallow folks.
That certainly can be it.
And so the argument that has been proposed is that the greater geographic and
physic and socio economic mobility in the United States today,
I'm an Atlanta,
tomorrow I'm in mountain view.
Today I am a lower level,
lower economic status.
Now I'm a DOTCOM billionaire.
That mobility causes people to have a different outlook on friendships.
Whereas when you come from the old country,
meaning any Lebanon,
Italy,
Greece,
India,
typically the place where you're born,
that little village where you were born is where you're going to typically die.
And therefore that's closer to the evolutionary environment in which we've
evolved,
right?
The,
the,
the networks are much tighter there.
They mimic much more the environment in which we evolved.
Whereas the environments that we see in our modern environment,
that they are not the ones that we've evolved in.
That's why in California,
for every single of the most banal exchanges,
you have a 600 page legal disclaimer form.
Right?
I remember when we moved from,
when we moved from Montreal to,
I was a professor at Uc Irvine.
The first place that we rented a townhouse,
the rental agreement was probably three times the size of the camp.
David accords between uh,
Egypt,
Lebanon and the United States in 1953 we pass the certain fumigation.
You can't sue us if in 17 generations one of your kids develops cancer.
You're reading through this,
you're saying,
I mean,
am I renting an apartment or is this like a nuclear reactors and what's going
on?
While the reason for that is because of the anonymity of the current environment
that we live in,
the social interactions have to be mandated by these contracts.
If you're back in Lebanon,
well,
I just have to shake your hand.
And that's enough.
Now that's not because the Lebanese are more honorable.
That's because if I cheat you once,
that's the last time I'm ever going to cheat you because I'm going to be in that
environment.
So you don't need the 7,000 page contract to mandate relationships.
So I argue that that's what drives the cross cultural differences and the depth
of friendships.
And for the last question,
um,
there seems to be a push against ascension in academia.
Um,
can you talk about that?
Is this a recent development of what was the first place?
There seems to be a push against ascension and I guess is this a recent
development or is this something that's been going on since the beginning of the
university system?
While it's certainly gotten worse over the past 30,
40 years?
Uh,
and so for those of you who follow my work,
I mean,
I really have two hats.
I both have the hat of,
you know,
an academic who publishes in journals and so on.
But I also weight in on many of these issues,
the political correctness,
the trigger warnings,
the microaggressions and so on that are taking place at the university that that
is making it very difficult to have interesting debates about controversial
topics because everybody is afraid that they might offend somebody.
I and actually the,
the topic of my next book,
which I'm currently working on is the tentative title is death of the West by a
thousand cuts.
I go into what has led us down this quagmire.
So no,
I don't think it's a recent thing.
I think it's taken about 40 years of horrifying,
full intellectual wisdom to lead us to the place where we are at and some of
these movements in case some of you want to know postmodernism,
everything is relative.
There are no objective truths,
cultural and moral relativism,
identity politics and intersectionality,
radical feminism.
Each of these movements are perfect.
Anti Science,
anti reason positions put them all together.
You get a cocktail,
you get a launch of utter nonsense.
That has led us to where we are.
So I'd like to think that there's a few of us now that are working to fight
against this.
Uh,
the news is still not good because I will often receive emails from professors,
tons of them who will write to me,
you know,
you were so inspired by you,
thank you for your courage,
but they'll never say it publicly.
As if supporting freedom of speech,
freedom of intellectual diversity is a controversial topic,
right?
They support freedom of speech,
but they're afraid to state so openly.
So we're in a,
we're in a difficult position,
but a few of us are,
are fighting very hard to try to reverse the trend.
Well,
thank you very much for coming here and speaking.
You flew across the country to make it here and short notice.
So if you can give him a round of applause.